[BLANK_AUDIO]
As part of this course, you'll be given access to a virtual machine that
contains an environment and tools that should aid your work for
the course. For example, the virtual machine has ARGO UML,
a UML-aware drawing tool. You are not required to use ARGO UML, but
it may enable you to get started more quickly with the UML related work.
There are other tools such as Eclipse installed as well. In addition to
the virtual machine you should also be aware of the class resources page.
It not only contains links to all the courses required readings, but
other items referenced in the lessons, and some pointers.
That should allow you to dig deeper into topics that interest you.
I encourage you to explore. Also, if you are aware of other interesting
resources, let us know on the class forum and we will add them to this page.